[Music]
have you ever wondered what would happen
if Disney Princesses switched lives
Pocahontas as Rapunzel Ariel as
Cinderella Aurora as jasmine the
combinations are endless get ready to
get your minds completely blown by these
amazing illustrations most of our future
drawings were done by an awesome
illustrator called Dylan Bonner think
you're a bigger Disney fan than us make
sure you subscribe to our channel to
never miss another video again now join
us as we look at fifteen Disney
Princesses who switched lives Belle and
Snow White Belle is the star of Beauty
and the Beast she's gorgeous intelligent
and very outspoken so what if Bell was
replaced by Snow White
check this out do you think the Beauty
and the Beast story would change with
Snow White as the main character instead
of Belle oddly enough she seems to fit
right in Belle's yellow dress
and although Belle's hair is long and
brown Snow White's short dark hair
really doesn't seem to stand out that
much do you think Snow White would be
able to play those part and stand up for
the people she loved the most Snow
White's voice was so unique the actress
who played her wasn't even allowed to
make another movie again with her
singing suit Belle's melodic voice we'd
bet there would be a lot more animals in
the beauty in the beasts Kingdom Jasmine
and Snow White
so Belen Snow White would definitely be
an interesting mix but how about jasmine
plain as Snow White this looks like a
pretty good match can you imagine the
fairest of them all with long dark hair
the two are also the two of the youngest
Disney Princesses so maybe this scenario
isn't even that far-fetched but we can
imagine jasmine wouldn't be very happy
in this role the Arabian princesses
choice of clothing usually includes
pants while Snow White was in her
beautiful yellow and blue dress Princess
Jasmine looks almost unrecognizable in a
dress could the two youngest princesses
switch lives the two also have
completely different voices while Snow
White's unique voice is high-pitched
Jasmine's is much deeper what would it
sound like if jasmine saying Snow
White's a smile and a song Pocahontas
and Rapunzel now here's an unusual
couple these two have nothing
common except for their long hair and
age yep
both Pocahontas and Rapunzel were 18 in
their movies but would they be able to
switch lives this picture sure think so
in fact it looks like Pocahontas is
easily fitting in Rapunzel's princess
dress and Pascal seems to like her too
do you think Pocahontas could play
Rapunzel's part they're completely
different characters with completely
different personalities
while Rapunzel is much more innocent and
childlike Pocahontas was wise and
faithful could the Native American
princess survive the tangled life in a
tower or would she make her way out a
lot earlier than Rapunzel did we can
certainly imagine Pocahontas standing up
to Rapunzel's mother and giving her a
piece of her mind
although Pocahontas is hair isn't as
long as Rapunzel's it definitely has an
impressive link Belle and Sleeping
Beauty we saw the Belle and snow white
combination so how about Belle and
Princess Aurora from Sleeping Beauty
here's a picture of Belle beam soundly
asleep waiting for her prince to give
her a kiss is that really so far away
from the story of the Beauty and the
Beast in fact did you know that there
are far more similarities between
Sleeping Beauty and Beauty and the Beast
their looks are both inspired by the
beautiful Audrey Hepburn and did you
know that Belle's dance with the Beast
is exactly the same as the dance between
Aurora and the Prince amazing right but
now that we think about it we don't see
any issues with Belle swapping lives
with Aurora
come on Disney make it happen Ariel and
Cinderella all right
Belle and Aurora make a perfect match
but what do you think about Ariel and
Cinderella to be completely honest
Ariel looks like a modern-day princess
with her long red hair and in
Cinderella's outfit
although both of them long to live a
different life they are set apart by
their personalities lost endure Ella is
forced to obey the rules
Ariel openly disagrees their stories do
have one more thing in common their feet
if they would change lives do you think
Ariel would put up with her stepsisters
attitudes we bet she put an end to it a
lot faster than Cinderella did but if
she did we'd never have the beautiful
Cinderella story we still can't get over
how amazing she looks in Cinderella's a
blue dress this is definitely one of our
favorite combination
Tiana and Elsa now this would be a very
interesting match would princess tiana
be able to take on the role of Elsa the
queen of ice elsa closes herself up and
leaves because she scared her powers
could hurt the people around her
on the opposite tiana is a hard-working
waitress who believes she can do
anything she sets her mind to as long as
she's patient completely different
characters right so what could Tiana
bring to the frozen story
BuzzFeed actually brought up a good
point that we have never seen Tiana
acting like as a princess most of the
princess in the frog movies she was
either working or she was a frog but
could Tiana fit in the frozen kingdom
most importantly would she be able to
sing let it go as well as Elsa does
Tiana asked Cinderella don't worry if
you ever wanted to know what Tiana would
look like if she acted like a princess
we got your back here's Tiana
transforming into her magical Cinderella
dress she looks absolutely wonderful
doesn't she did you know that Tiana is
the only Disney princess with dimples
how cute is that Tiana's hard work ethic
would definitely be a game changer in
the story of Cinderella there's an
interesting theory about Tiana and
Cinderella both princesses were married
into royalty but along with Belle
they're also the only princesses that
are wearing opera gloves yes all other
princesses who were born into royalty
have bare hands don't believe us
see for yourself is this a clever hint
done by Disney are just a circumstance
whatever it is our mind is officially
blown Snow White and Ariel now this is
the only illustration from our selection
that wasn't designed by the talented
Dylan Bonner instead this image belongs
to a deviantART user Ahn who turned snow
white into a unique version of Ariel
what do you think we love how the artist
kept Snow White's unique colors of her
dress and made it somehow work
considering Snow White would actually be
a mermaid she looks very happy but she's
still not letting go of that Apple can
you imagine Snow White singing part of
your world
or any other The Little Mermaid classics
we have no doubt she'd get along with
flounder since Snow White is practically
the queen of all animals this would
certainly be an interesting mix of the
two completely different worlds and who
we'd love to see how it would play out
on the big screen Cinderella and Tiana
so you know what Tiana would look like
dresses Cinderella but how about
Cinderella dresses Tiana we can
definitely see this combination work
Cinderella is pretty friendly with
animals anyways so a talking frog would
suit her just fine we love her hair and
her green gown
not to mention that both princesses
share the same age did you know that in
the early drafts Cinderella actually had
a pet turtle named Clarissa perhaps
these two princesses share more
similarities than we think when Disney
fans stated that both princesses were
overworked and have the typical rags to
riches story line but that's not all
have you ever noticed how similar both
of their ball gowns look who do you
think wore better no wonder why it's so
easy to imagine Cinderella and tiana
switching lives Aurora and jasmine now
here's a very interesting pair could
Sleeping Beauty take on the life of
Princess Jasmine the two couldn't be
more opposite but by judging by this
picture Aurora could easily fill in
Jasmine's shoes Jasmine is probably one
of the trendiest Disney Princesses she
is sporting harem pants and crop tops
and she definitely does it well Aurora's
fashion is best known for her beautiful
long dress it's definitely weird seeing
Aurora in Jasmine's outfit but we think
that blue harem pants and crop top
really go with her long blonde hair and
she's also matching with the genie do
you think Aurora would be ready to enter
the world of Aladdin she'd have to fill
in the shoes of a very confident and
headstrong princess both princesses do
share a similar value love so perhaps
they aren't that opposite after all
Rapunzel and Pocahontas speaking of
interesting pairs what do you think of
this we've looked at Pocahontas
replacing Rapunzel but this scene is
definitely interesting
Rapunzel is getting her hair skillfully
braided by Miko we all know Miko's
braiding skills are on point so perhaps
you could use a little challenge like
Rapunzel's long hair and we can see
these two getting along really well
but what Rapunzel be able to take on the
world of Pocahontas we're talking having
an interracial relationship as well as a
tattoo and she'd have to replace her
lilac dress with an awesome native
outfit both princesses are exactly the
same age and they're both headstrong in
their own ways what do you think
Rapunzel would bring to Pocahontas story
we can see how her 70 feet long
might get in the way of Pocahontas daily
activities Arielle and Belle check out
this picture is that Ariel dress up as
Belle and it looks like she fits right
in the scenery
perhaps Ariel was always meant to live
the life on land and perhaps the land
was in the world of Beauty and the Beast
this is amazing the two princesses are
just one year apart in age but we
definitely see a few similarities would
she be ready for the role of not being
born in royalty and having to put up
with the overconfident Gaston although
Belle is a year older than Ariel we
believe she could learn a thing or two
from a brave and feisty Little Mermaid
Ariel was also ranked as the best Disney
princess when it came to wardrobe she
can pretty much wear anything and it
still looks good Elsa and Ariel so Ariel
would do fine on land but would another
princess do fine in water check out this
image of Elsa and Anna in the Little
Mermaid world don't they look awesome
Elsa looks like she's got the full
control of the world underwater while
Anna and flounder are scared of Ursula
Elsa seems to be dealing with her like
it's nothing way to go Elsa there's
actually a fan theory that ties in
frozen and Little Mermaid remember Anna
and Elsa's parents fans claim that the
shipwreck they salad on is actually the
shipwreck you could see in the Little
Mermaid frozen is claimed to be set in
Norway while the Loon mermaid was based
on the coast of Denmark the two
countries are separated by the sea could
it really be that the wrecked ship and
The Little Mermaid belongs to us as
parents Merida and Mulan
it's the ultimate Disney question who
would win the free spirited Merida or
the adventurous Mulan what if we told
you that these Disney Princesses switch
lives
here's Merida replacing Mulan and she
definitely looks like she's ready to
fight who do you think is the better
warrior while Merida has a very good
range with her bow and arrows Mulan has
her sword while both princesses
definitely have their own irreplaceable
skill sets we think Merida would need to
step up her game and take a training
camp to ever be on the same level as
Milan but Merida has the fighting spirit
that confidence the independence and she
is the first official Disney princess
that needs no man to finish her story
how awesome would it be if Merida
actually got to play Mulan Mulan and
mayor
so we think Merida would definitely fit
in the world of Mulan but how about
Mulan deal with Merida's adventures as
you might know using the bow and arrow
isn't exactly Milan's greatest skill but
judging by this picture she has no issue
with archery somehow we can just picture
Mulan with a Scottish accent can't you
it would definitely give us a few
giggles but hey who are we to judge
based on this picture
Mulan would totally Rock a bow and arrow
and we know she'd stand up to her
parents the exact same way Merida stood
up to hers two iconic and incredibly
brave princesses definitely belong in
their own category of inspirational
Disney characters but we still didn't
get an answer to our question which
princess is better Mulan or Merida which
two Disney worlds would you combine and
why let us know in the comments below
and don't forget to give this video a
thumbs up if you're a huge fan of Disney
for more videos like this one check out
10 most epic Disney movie themed
bedrooms
ever see you in the next video
[Music]